FOR OUR BREAKING NEWS, BUSY NEWS
NIGHT, OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE SEVENTH FBI
BACKGROUND CHECK INTO JUDGE
KAVANAUGH IS FINISHED, AND NOW A
CONFIRMATION VOTE FOR JUDGE
BRETT KAVANAUGH COULD COME AS
EARLY AS SATURDAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE IS LOOKING
FORWARD TO THIS BOAT.
>> President Trump: THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
DESTROY JUDGE BRETT KAVANAUGH.
[BOOS]
SINCE THE VERY FIRST SECOND HE
WAS ANNOUNCED, AND HE WAS
ANNOUNCED FOR ONE SIMPLE REASON.
HE HAS AN INCREDIBLE INTELLECT,
AN INCREDIBLE PERSON, AN
INCREDIBLE TALENT.
HE HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE JUDGE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT JUDGE
KAVANAUGH WILL PROTECT, UPHOLD,
AND DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: TONIGHT, MANY U.S.
SENATORS SAY THEY ARE ON THE
FENCE, BUT RESPONDING POSITIVELY
TO TODAY'S FBI REPORT.
ACCORDING TO SENATOR JEFF FLAKE,
A SWING VOTE, THE REPORT
REVEALED ZERO NEW EVIDENCE
AGAINST KAVANAUGH.
SUNDER COLLINS OF MAINE, ANOTHER
CRUCIAL SWING VOTE, PRAISED THE
INVESTIGATION FOR BEING VERY
THOROUGH.
HERE IS BOTTOM LINE.
IF BOTH FLAKE AND COLLINS VOTE
IN FAVOR OF JUDGE KAVANAUGH, HE
WILL BE A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
TODAY AT A VERY FIERY PRESS
CONFERENCE, SENATE REPUBLICANS
HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT THE
IMPENDING VOTE AND THIS HORRIFIC
PROCESS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT WE KNOW FOR SURE IS THE
FBI REPORT DID NOT CORROBORATE
ANY OF THE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST A
JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
>> THIS IS THE 87TH DAY -- THAT
IS THREE WEEKS LONGER THAN THE
AVERAGE OF THE LAST THREE OR
FOUR CONOMINEES TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
SO DON'T TELL ME WE HAVEN'T
SPENT ENOUGH TIME.
WHAT I HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH
SINCE JULY 10TH, THE DOWNHILL
SLOPE THAT CHUCK SCHUMER HAS PUT
US ON
IS REALLY DEALING WITH A
DEMOLITION DERBY.
THEY JUST ABOUT DESTROYED A GOOD
PERSON, TO BE ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
A VOTE AGAINST JUDGE KAVANAUGH
TOMORROW WILL BE A VOTE FOR
ABUSING THE CONFIRMATION PROCESS
AND A GOOD PERSON.
AND IT WILL BE A VOTE FOR THE
SHAMEFUL INTIMIDATION TACTICS
THAT HAVE BEEN EMPLOYED AS PART
OF AN ORCHESTRATED SMEAR
CAMPAIGN.
>> THIS IS A SEARCH AND DESTROY
MISSION.
THIS IS NOT A SEARCH FOR THE
TRUTH.
>> Sean: AND TONIGHT IS
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER, MORE
DOCUMENTATION WAS PROVIDED
TO THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, THAN ANY
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE IN
HISTORY.
SO FAR, THIS NOMINATION PROCESS
IS THE THIRD LONGEST IN THE PAST
50 YEARS, BUT TONIGHT, THE SMEAR
MERCHANTS ON THE LEFT ARE IN
FULL ON FREAK OUT MODE.
SENATE DEMOCRATS WILL ALL
DEMANDED AN FBI INVESTIGATION TE
DONE QUICKLY WITH LIMITED SCOPE,
JUST LAST WEEK, NOW TRASHING
THAT VERY SAME FBI INVESTIGATIO
INVESTIGATION.
NEW JERSEY SENATOR BOB MENENDEZ,
HE CALLED IT A B.S.
INVESTIGATION ON TWITTER.
THE WHINING CONTINUED WHEN THERE
IS A TELEVISION CAMERA IN FRONT
OF THESE PUBLICITY HUNGRY
DEMOCRATS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE DEMOCRATS HAD MANY FEARS
THAT THIS WOULD BE AN ALL TOO
LIMITED PROCESS THAT WOULD
CONSTRAIN THE FBI FROM GETTING
THE FACTS.
HAVING RECEIVED A THOROUGH
BRIEFING A FEW MINUTES AGO, OUR
FEARS HAVE BEEN REALIZED.
>> THIS SET OF INTERVIEWS IS, AT
BEST, MOST CHARITABLY, WOEFULLY
INCOMPLETE.
TO PUT IT BLUNTLY, IT SMACKS OF
A COVER-UP.
>> IN YOUR VIEW, IS THIS A
CREDIBLE INVESTIGATION?
>> IT IS OBVIOUSLY A COVER-UP.
THEY ARE MAKING A MOCKERY OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT THAT
THE SENATE PROVIDE ITS ADVICE
AND CONSENT.
>> THAT REPORT IS A LEAP
INVESTIGATION.
TO >> Sean: EVERY ONE OF THESE
DEMOCRATS WERE AGAINST JUDGE
KAVANAUGH OR ANYONE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD HAVE
NOMINATED TO THE COURT.
ON THIS PROGRAM, WE HAVE EXPOSED
THE FEW, THE FEW, TOP ECHELON,
AND THE FBI I DID ABUSE THEIR
POWER, WE HAVE MADE A POINT ON
THE NIGHTLY BASIS TO STAND UP
FOR THE RANK-AND-FILE, FIELD
AGENTS, THE ONES THAT RISKED
THEIR LIVES, LIKE OTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT, FOR US, EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
INCLUDING THOSE THAT CONDUCTED
THE SUPPLEMENTAL BACKGROUND
CHECK.
THE FBI ACTED IN A FAIR
INDEPENDENT MANNER PEERED SOME
ON THE LEFT DON'T LIKE THE
RESULTS, THE CALL FOR A MORE
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION IS BEYOND
ABSURD.
WHAT IS THE FBI SUPPOSED TO DO?
WE DON'T HAVE A LOCATION TO
INVESTIGATE, NO DATE TO
INVESTIGATE.
THERE IS NO PHYSICAL EVIDENCE,
THERE IS NO FORENSIC EVIDENCE.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW THE DAY OF
THE WEEK.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT
PROFESSOR FORD LISTED TO
CORROBORATE HER STORY DENIED ANY
KNOWLEDGE OF HER CLAIMS.
THE ONE I WITNESS THAT SHE
LISTED, TOTALLY REFUTED HER
CLAIMS.
EVEN LONGTIME FRIEND HAD NO IDEA
WHAT SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
THEY'LL REFUTED HER CLAIMS UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY.
NOW TWICE.
THE OTHER ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
KAVANAUGH, THEY ARE EVEN MORE
SHAKY.
THE SECOND ACCUSER MAKING
DECADES-OLD CLAIMS THAT
KAVANAUGH HAD EXPOSED HIMSELF AS
A FRESHMAN IN COLLEGE AT A
PARTY.
SHE WASN'T EVEN SURE THAT
KAVANAUGH WAS THE PERPETRATOR.
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
WOULDN'T PUBLISH HER CLAIMS, AND
THEY SEARCHED FAR AND WIDE FOR
EVIDENCE TO CORROBORATE HER
STORY.
THEY FOUND NOTHING, EXCEPT THAT
SHE HAD BEEN MAKING CALLS TO
OTHER YO CLASSMATES AT THE TIME
SAYING, I'M NOT SURE IT IS HIM,
DO YOU REMEMBER?
THE THIRD ACCUSER, SYSTEMATIC,
DRUGGING, GANG RAPE ALLEGATION
AGAINST TEENAGE GIRLS GET HER
STORY HAS IT CHANGED MANY TIMES
IN ABOUT A WEEK.
SHE IS FACING SERIOUSLY
CREDIBILITY ISSUES.
OF COURSE, REPRESENTED BY
MICHAEL AVENATTI, LAWYER OF THE
YEAR.
NONE OF THESE ALLEGATIONS HAVE
DATES, LOCATIONS, WITNESSES,
EVIDENCE, CORROBORATION, OF ANY
KIND, OF ANY OF THESE CLAIMS.
SO DO DEMOCRATS REALLY EXPECT TO
BE FBI TO MAGICALLY FIND
DECADES-OLD EVIDENCE PROVING
THAT KAVANAUGH WAS AN EVIL
PREDATOR, SYSTEMIC GAME RANK IS,
SOMEBODY THAT DRUGGED
TEENAGE GIRLS.
THEY REALLY BELIEVE THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULD SUSPEND
ALL DECENCY AND COMMON SENSE AND
A BELIEF THAT A MAN WITH AN
IMPECCABLE 40 YEAR TRACK RECORD
WAS REALLY SECRETLY A MONSTER IN
HIS YOUTH AND DID THIS ALMOST ON
A WEEKLY BASIS?
IN REALITY, THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN
ABOUT POLITICS AND POWER.
A DELAY TACTIC.
A TRANSPARENT ATTEMPT TO
LITERALLY RUIN A MAN'S LIFE,
DESTROY HIS FAMILY.
BECAUSE THEY LOST AN ELECTION
AND THEY WANT THE POWER.
THIS HAS BECOME A NATIONAL
DISGRACE.
IN SOME CASES, THESE POLITICAL
TACTICS WORKED.
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR FROM
NORTH DAKOTA, HEIDI HEITKAMP, BY
THE WAY, NOW DOWN 11 IN THE
LATEST POLL, CAME TO BE AN
INDEPENDENT VOICE FOR THE PEOPLE
OF NORTH DAKOTA.
TONIGHT, WE KNOW SHE IS NOTHING
MORE THAN A SHILL FOR
CHUCK SCHUMER AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
SHE ASSUMED SHE IS NOT GETTING
REELECTED, SO SHE IS TRASHING
THE WILL OF HER OWN CONSTITUENTS
IN VOTING "NO."
YOU HAVE JOHN DONNELLY, OF
INDIANA, ALSO A "NO" VOTE.
INDIANA VOTERS, YOU CAN SEND HIM
A MESSAGE AND GET OUT AND VOTE.
NOW WE ARE SEEING THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY -- LITERALLY, THEIR
PLAYBOOK ROLL OUT IN FULL FORCE.
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE
CHRONICLED ON A REGULAR BASIS ON
THE SHOW, WE NOW BEGIN OUR 23RD
YEAR ON THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL, 30
IN RADIO.
A BIG CRESCENDO INTO ONE OF THE
MOST DESPICABLE DISPLAYS IN
ANYTHING WE HAVE OTHER
WITNESSED.
I WARNED YOU THEY ARE GOING TO
TRY TO THWART KAVANAUGH OR
WHOEVER THE PRESIDENT PICKED AND
BRING BACK THE CLARA THOMAS
TACTICS.
THE SMEAR MACHINE ON THE LEFT IS
IN FULL GEAR.
SOME ARE CLAIMING THE
ALLEGATIONS DIDN'T WORK, LET'S
GO AFTER JUDGE KAVANAUGH'S
TEMPERAMENT.
THAT MIGHT BE DISQUALIFIED.
SAYING HE WAS JUST TOO
AGGRESSIVE WHEN DEFENDING
HIMSELF AGAINST FALSE
ALLEGATIONS OF DRUGGING AND GANG
RAPING TEENAGE GIRLS.
ASK YOURSELF THIS QUESTION.
HOW WOULD YOU REACT IF YOU WERE
FALSELY ACCUSED OF RAPE?
OF DRUGGING TEENAGE GIRLS?
HAPPENED ON AN EVERY WEEKEND
BASIS.
GANG RAPING THEM, BOYS LINING UP
AND HE HALTED HOW WOULD YOU
REACT?
WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE
REACTION?
HOW WOULD YOU REACT IF SENATORS
WERE ON NATIONAL TV CALLING YOU
EVIL, COMPARING YOU TO
BILL COSBY, SUGGESTING THAT YOU
ARE GUILTY OF SERIOUS CRIMES YOU
NEVER COMMITTED?
FAR LEFT RETIRED JUSTICE
JOHN PAUL STEVENS WEIGHING IN,
THIS SHOULD DISQUALIFY HIM FROM
BECOMING A JUSTICE.
THIS IS THE SAME RADICAL FORMER
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE THAT
DOESN'T BELIEVE IN THE
CONSTITUTION BEER HE ONCE
DEMANDED THE SECOND AMENDMENT BE
DEMANDED THE SECOND AMENDMENT BR
DEMANDED THE SECOND AMENDMENT BP
DEMANDED THE SECOND AMENDMENT BA
DEMANDED THE SECOND AMENDMENT BE
DEMANDED THE SECOND AMENDMENT B.
WROTE THAT THE ELECTION OF
GEORGE W. BUSH VIOLATED OUR
CONSTITUTION PEER JUST MOMENTS
AGO, JUDGE KAVANAUGH, IN AN
OP-ED JUST
RELEASED WITH
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," HE
ELOQUENTLY DEFENDED HIMSELF ON
THE EVE OF WHAT WILL BE A
HISTORIC VOTE.
THIS IS A TIPPING POINT FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
HE TALKED ABOUT THESE RIDICULOUS
ALLEGATIONS THAT HE WROTE,
"AFTER ALL THOSE MEETINGS AND
AFTER MY INITIAL HEARING
CONCLUDED, I WAS SUBJECTED TO
WRONGFUL, SOMETIMES VICIOUS,
ALLEGATIONS.
MY TIME IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE, MORE THAN 30 YEARS AGO,
HAS BEEN RIDICULOUSLY DISTORTED.
MY WIFE, MY DAUGHTERS, HAVE
FACED A VILE VIOLENT THREATS.
AGAINST THAT BACKDROP, I
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE LAST THURSDAY TO
DEFEND MY FAMILY, MY GOOD NAME,
MY LIFETIME A PUBLIC SERVICE, MY
HEARING TESTIMONY WAS FORCEFUL
AND PASSIONATE.
THAT IS BECAUSE I FORCEFULLY AND
PASSIONATELY DENIED THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST ME.
HE CONTINUED, I WAS VERY
EMOTIONAL LAST THURSDAY.
MORE SO THAN I HAVE EVER BEEN.
I MIGHT HAVE BEEN TOO EMOTIONAL
AT TIMES.
I KNOW THAT MY TONE WAS SHARP, I
SAID A FEW THINGS I SHOULD NOT
HAVE SAID.
HE DID APOLOGIZE ONCE IN THE
HEARINGS.
I HOPE THAT EVERYONE CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT I WAS THERE AS A
SON, A HUSBAND, A DAD, AND I
TESTIFIED WITH FIVE PEOPLE
FOREMOST IN MY MIND.
MY MOM, MY DAD, MY WIFE, AND
MOST OF ALL, MY TWO DAUGHTERS.
SADLY, THIS KIND OF COMMON SENSE
AND LOGIC AND DECENCY FROM JUDGE
KAVANAUGH, IT MEANS NOTHING TO
THE LEFT.
HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND?
BY THE WAY, IT MEANS NOTHING TO
THEIR COHORTS, THEIR FRIENDS, IN
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
YOU OF ALL THE PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT WHINING, CRYING,
COMPLAINING, THOSE THAT BELIEVE
THAT GUILT BY ACCUSATION -- JUST
DOING WHAT THEY DO BEST TODAY.
FEIGNING OUTRAGE.
BY THE WAY, WHEN DID ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, THE SNOWFLAKES ON THE
FLOOR OF THE SENATE BEING TAKEN
OUT ALL DAY, DID THEY EVER
PROTESTED BILL CLINTON LIKE
THIS?
DID THEY EVER STAND UP FOR
JUANITA BROADDRICK, KATHLEEN
WILLEY, PAULA JONES?
OH, THAT'S RIGHT, DIANNE
FEINSTEIN, WHO RECOMMENDED DEBRA
KATZ, DEBRA KATZ DID NOT BELIEVE
IN PAULA JONES.
IT WAS ONLY TEN OR 12:     12 MI
IT WAS ONLY TEN OR 12:     12 MU
IT WAS ONLY TEN OR 12:     12 ME
IT WAS ONLY TEN OR 12:     12 M.
FEIGNED, SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE
HERE TODAY YOU ARE FAR LEFT
PROTESTERS ERUPTING ALL OVER
CAPITOL HILL.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, EMOTIONS
WERE RUNNING HIGH.
LOGIC WAS RUNNING VERY LOW.
EVEN SENT OUR OWN CHRIS JENKINS
TO THE MIDDLE OF ALL OF THIS IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE MOM COME
ASKING THESE PEOPLE WHAT THEY
THOUGHT ABOUT DUE PROCESS,
THE PRESUMPTION OF IMMINENT
SENSE, THE RULE OF LAW.
THE ANSWERS MOST ON YOU, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> THERE IS NO RESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE IN A JOB INTERVIEW.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE HE WAS GIVEN A
FAIR CHANCE IN HIS CONFIRMATION.
>> A FAIR CHANCE?
MISS AMANDA SITTING AMONG
FRIENDS OF HIS PEERS >> CLEARLY
THERE BEEN ENOUGH ALLEGATIONS
THAT WE KNOW THIS
JOB APPLICATION NEEDS TO BE
DENIED.
>> THE PUBLIC ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD BE MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT
WHAT THEY DESERVE, NOT THE
[BLEEP] RICH WHITE MAN WHO
DOESN'T GIVE A [BLEEP] ABOUT US.
>> JUDGE KAVANAUGH MADE IT
PRETTY CLEAR THAT HE DOES NOT
HAVE THE JUDICIAL TEMPERAMENT,
HE BELIEVES THE SUPREME COURT IS
JUST ONE MORE POLITICAL
FOOTHOLD.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE
SUPREME COURT IS ABOUT, AND I
THINK IN THAT HEARING, JUDGE
KAVANAUGH DISQUALIFIED HIMSELF.
>> Sean: NOPE RESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, NO DUE PROCESS.
LET ME TELL YOU, THAT IS THE
CASE, THERE IS NO COUNTRY, THERE
IS NO CONSTITUTION.
IT IS SAD, IT IS SHOCKING, AND
IT IS FRANKLY BEYOND CHILLING.
COMING UP, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
A LOT MORE, INCLUDING HIS FULL
INTERVIEW WITH SENATOR ELIZABETH
WARREN PEER TODAY, SHE LED THIS
HORDE OF DEMONSTRATORS DEMANDING
THAT KAVANAUGH'S LIFE AND
NOMINATION
BE -- REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE ALLS
BE -- REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE ALLA
BE -- REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE ALLE
BE -- REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE ALL.
THERE HAS TO BE SUMP RESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE.
THE ONLY GOOD NEWS TONIGHT IS
THE LEFT, THEY HAVE BEEN
OFFICIALLY EXPOSED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SEE THOSE PROTESTERS?
YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE RADICAL
LEFT DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE PARTY OF SMEARS, LIES,
CHARACTER ASSASSINATIONS.
FAMILY BLUDGEONING WITH NO PLANS
TO OFFER THE HARDWORKING,
LAW-ABIDING, TAXPAYING CITIZENS,
YOU COME OF THE AMERICAN WHO
MAKE THIS COUNTRY THE SINGLE
GREATEST BEST LAST GREAT HOPE
FOR MAN ON THIS EARTH.
THAT IS NOT THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT IS ONE PARTY, THOUGH SADLY,
THAT HAS ABANDONED ANY SENSE OF
FUNDAMENTAL DECENCY, FAIRNESS,
AND COMMON SENSE.
THANKFULLY, YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, IT IS NOW AWOKEN A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY.
NOTE LOOK AT THIS RASMUSSEN POLL
ON PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE HIGHEST
APPROVAL RATING EVER.
ACCORDING TO AN NPR POLL OF ALL
PLACES, REMEMBER THE DEMOCRATIC
ENTHUSIASM, BLUE WAVE THAT THEY
HAD?
IT IS TOTALLY EVAPORATED PEER
TODAY, AT THIS HOUR, WE ARE SEEN
TODAY, AT THIS HOUR, WE ARE SEEG
TODAY, AT THIS HOUR, WE ARE SEET
TODAY, AT THIS HOUR, WE ARE SEEE
TODAY, AT THIS HOUR, WE ARE SEEC
TODAY, AT THIS HOUR, WE ARE SEEA
TODAY, AT THIS HOUR, WE ARE SEES
TODAY, AT THIS HOUR, WE ARE SEE,
TODAY, AT THIS HOUR, WE ARE SEET
TODAY, AT THIS HOUR, WE ARE SEEE
INSANITY.
YOUR LEADERS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, FULL ON ASSAULT OF THE
INTEGRITY OF THE FBI.
THERE ARE SO CONVINCED THEIR
PARTY ACTIVISTS ABOUT GUILT UPON
ACCUSATION THAT THAT IS FINE IN
AMERICA, NO DUE PROCESS, IT'S
FINE IN AMERICA.
NO PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE IS
FINE FOR IT HOW DOES THAT WORK
FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY IN YOUR
LIFE?
SLANDER, SMEAR, CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION, THAT IS ONE PARTY
IN AMERICA TODAY.
GREAT JOB, DIANNE FEINSTEIN,
CHUCKIE SCHUMER, MAXINE WATERS,
NANCY PELOSI.
DO YOU WANT THEM IN POWER AND 33
DAYS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE
CAUSING PANDEMONIUM IN THE
NATION'S CAPITAL BECAUSE THEIR
SO-CALLED LEADERS CONVINCED THEM
THAT GUILT BY ACCUSATION IS OKA
OKAY.
THAT DEFINING SOMEONE AS A
RAPIST, A GANG RAPIST IS OKAY?
THOSE ARE THE TACTICS OF TODAY'S
RADICAL DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THIS IS WHY, FOR YEARS, I
POINTED THIS OUT ON THE SHOW.
THIS HAPPENS EVERY TWO GOING
FOUR YEARS, AND NOW WITH EVERY
SUPREME COURT APPOINTMENT.
NEARLY EVERYONE.
THEY DISSEMINATED SALACIOUS LIES
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP BEFORE AND
AFTER THE ELECTION.
THEY ADVANCED A BIZARRE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT ONE
CANDIDATE ACTUALLY PAID FOR.
HOOKERS URINATING EMBEDS.
THEY DO IT TO START UP A
WITCH HUNT INVESTIGATION AND
CONSPIRACY.
THEY CALL PEOPLE RACIST, SEXIST,
MISOGYNISTIC, XENA PHOBIC,
HOMOPHOBIC, ISLAMOPHOBIC.
WE DRINK THE WATER AND BREATHE
THE AIR.
WE WANT CHILDREN TO DIE.
YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO RAISE
MEDICARE 7% PER YEAR, YOU WANT
TO THROW YOUR OWN GRANDMOTHER
OFF THE CLIFF.
WE HEAR IT EVERY TWO AND FOUR
YEARS.
WHEN THESE VILE ACCUSATIONS OF
DRUGGING, GANG RAPING TEENAGE
GIRLS WITHOUT EVIDENCE, NOT TO
BE BELIEVED BY THE FBI, THESE
ARE THE CONSEQUENCES, THAT IS
THE REACTION?
IS THIS THE PARTY YOU WANT IN
POWER?
YOU WANT TO ELECT THESE PEOPLE
AND 33 DAYS?
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
HIGH DRAMA TONIGHT WITH THESE
FOUR SENATORS.
THEY APPEAR TO HOLD THE KEYS TO
THE KAVANAUGH BOAT.
ARE THEY GOING TO GIVE IN TO
THIS NEW AMERICA OF GUILT BY
ACCUSATION, LYING, SMEARING,
SLANDER, CHARACTER BLUDGEONING?
OF THE LAST 17 DAYS PEER FORGET
THE LAST 40 YEARS OF THIS MAN'S
LIFE.
NO CORROBORATION.
ARE THEY GOING TO GIVE INTO
THIS?
HAS ANY OF THIS HAD ANY IMPACT
ON THOSE FOUR SENATORS?
DO THEY BELIEVE IN THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE?
THAT IS THEIR QUESTION TONIGHT.
DO THEY BELIEVE IN DUE PROCESS,
THE RULE OF LAW?
TO THEY HAVE COMMON SENSE AND
DECENCY?
DO THEY BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE SOME CORROBORATION?
DO THEY BELIEVE IN OUR GREAT
CONSTITUTION?